we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p hey guys
there's something really exciting a
reality show producer reached out and is
inviting me to maybe be the next
Bachelor take a listen
David this is rusty from Hollywood I'm
here to offer you a role as the next
year's bachelor call me back yeah of
course
you know the real mistake I think is
that the producers don't live in
Hollywood the producers live elsewhere
in nicer places usually than Hollywood
but maybe the guy's office is in
Hollywood okay thank you yes I would
love to appear I would love to be the
next bachelor let's see if we can make
it happen on today's bonus show was
Martin Luther King a Republican or a
Democrat it is Martin Luther King Day
and we're going to have a conversation
about that and the answer is that it's
complicated and we will also talk about
how Martin Luther King's political views
have been misstated for personal gain by
lots of different political players and
figures all of that on the bonus show we
will also talk about the European Union
wants all smartphones to have a standard
charging port and this is an issue that
relates to many different issues
including accessibility of Technology
there's a privacy component to it
there's an intellectual property
component to it we're going to talk
about that and in general we're going to
talk about European regulation of
businesses versus American regulation of
businesses and most most of you probably
can guess one of the big distinctions
there which is that in Europe they much
more proactively a regulating business
and lastly Donald Trump's border wall
even without getting built could be one
of the world's most costly what does
that mean I will explain it on the bonus
show two ways to get access to the bonus
show which we produce every single day
for our members and patrons number one
go to join pakman.com sign up for a
membership it takes a minute probably
not even a minute if you're pretty good
with computers probably thirty seconds
you can use the coupon code twenty
twenty now to save sixty-six percent for
a limited time you can also become a
patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
at the $5 a month or greater level five
dollars and ten cents a month qualifies
you six dollars and 73 cents a month
qualifies you is just gotta be five
bucks a month or more and you'll get
instant access to the bonus show sign up
either way both ways I'll speak to you
on the bonus show in mere moments